we're going to the phone lines we've got
chloe on the line chloe how can we help
you
hi thank you so much for taking my call
um
i recently uh this year just
started with the financial piece and
getting my life
on track so i'm on baby step two my
husband and i good
and um i had a question
um we see that we're probably going to
be down to
our final two debts um in a couple of
months
and one is a really really really big
student loan
and um that's our last debt
and i wanted to find out if my student
loan
is more than a mortgage i have
yes it is um do i still attack the
student loan
because the mortgage is not in baby step
two okay gotcha good question
and chloe i i just want to back up here
because you had a lot of really
release as you were describing that
student loan
you said a really really really big
student loan
how big is this i'm not a doctor i'm
about to ask you are you a surgeon of
some sort
no no no i i now know how
terrible terrible terrible of an idea
this was
but no i am not a doctor or lawyer
and my student loans total about 123
thousand dollars
oh that's not a lot chloe what
we've had a million dollars okay let me
back it up that's a ton of money that's
six figures that's huge
i thought you were about to drop a
million dollars honestly 350 000. so let
me back it up
chloe that's a lot that's a lot it's not
what i had in my head it's not what i
had in my head
chloe how many degrees did you get for
this dollar amount
i have well technically i have a
bachelor's and a master's but
i haven't i started out with an
associate's degree but yeah
all right okay so what's your household
income
about 200 000 okay
and this student loan of 123 what else
you owe on
um right now we're still we're still
working baby step two and i have
my car that's 5900
that's the second to the last uh debt
the rest is like a 1500 um
credit card and an 1800
um we owe taxes for this year
and um another credit card for
2 900. okay you got the whole assortment
here and how much is owed on the
mortgage
how much do you owe on the home so the
mortgage is about 89 000
okay all right so in looking at this
first and foremost
got a couple things got to happen chloe
i'm gonna have to have you shift your
thinking
okay okay because right now what you're
doing is you're feeling the weight of
the
of the of being what's called normal
with the various credit cards
and and things and i i really want you
to get super serious
how old are you young lady i'm 38.
okay i want you to get hyper focused now
i'm going to answer your question
what would you do because of the size of
this you're still going to attack the
student loan debt
before the mortgage okay because we're
talking about now consumer debt
so the credit card that you have for
1500 is going to be
the first thing you're going to attack
uh first thing you're going to attack
actually the taxes
okay that that thing's going to go to
the top of the list because there's
penalties and interest that can accrue
on it
but then you're going to work through
the taxes then the credit card then to
the car
then to the student loan and that's the
mindset you're gonna have around it
once you pay that off then you're gonna
again you completed baby step two
now you're gonna start to build up your
emergency fund then you'll start to
invest then you'll save for college
then attack the house so the the baby
steps they won't change just because of
the size of the debt
uh so you're that's the process and
that's the math you're gonna have to
follow
and psychologically you're gonna have to
really decide on this
and i'm going to tell you i want you to
close these credit cards
close them call them and shut them down
uh don't just cut it up and send me a
photo because people know how to call
and get a duplicate card
hello born at night it just wasn't last
night and so i want you to shut it down
and when you do that that's where you go
from the difference of talking about it
to being about it
and that's what has to happen because
there's going to be stupid out there
lurking waiting on you to sign up for it
offers are going to come in the mail
there are computers there are algorithms
designed to hack your brain and get that
plastic
out of your wallet you ever notice how
you talk about things and that pops up
on your computer
yeah they're listening yeah i know i
shouldn't have said that around you
i forgot you're one of those conspiracy
theory dudes between you and rachel cruz
not a conspiracy theory if it's
true okay settle down settle down but
here's the thing
doesn't matter what they do out there we
have to learn how to stand up for
ourselves that's right and say no
and i'm telling you chloe for i want you
to do that
i hear it in your voice and you're like
teetering like you're interested
in kind of getting out of debt and maybe
it'll work out like that's kind of
i no i want you to get the mindset of
we're doing this this is the direction
we're going
and i'm not falling for this stuff
anymore and the difference between the
two
is one that will do it versus one that's
gonna stop at the first time you hit an
impasse
the first obstacle and it's not
commitment nope and here's the deal
chloe's got a big shovel to dig out of
this hole 200 000
a year they can go
go wild get gazelle intense 24 months
they could have cleared up a big chunk
of this debt all of it oh i completely
agree 24 months
that's two two years right and and again
people say
oh gosh it sounds like forever no no not
when i know people that have had student
loans hanging around for 16 plus
right you know and so realistically
somebody's my age
who are doctors and professors whose
kids are going to college
and they're still paying on their
student loans yeah it's real